I am a web software developer are you
hiring or can I volunteer for anything I
can build anything I can automate things
I could simply be an assistant of sorts
thank you for your time well what I
would like to say about that is first
Thank You Adam it's much appreciated and
a lot of people have volunteered their
time to me and their and their
technological expertise and as much as
I'd like to make use of it that simple
truth of the matter is that I'm
sufficiently overwhelmed by the
complexity of my life at the moment that
it's very difficult to undertake a new
collaborative project with anyone I mean
generally speaking before all this
political what would you call it before
all these political events overtook my
life I was already scheduled probably
about six months to a year out you know
all my time was already eaten up and of
course the addition of everything that's
happened in the last year - that has
occupied my time to a degree that is was
is really somewhat unimaginable and so I
just can't take on additional help which
is so strange because you think that
help is help and that it would save time
but you know it's very difficult to
mentor into a collaborative relationship
with someone and especially if you want
to give them credit and do things
properly so at the moment I'm afraid
that I can't entertain any such offers
even though I'd like to and there may
come a time in the future especially
when I'm hopefully starting to work more
on this online university project I've
got a few projects to finish up before
that the new personality test which
we've just about dawdled bugs worked out
of and also the high school version of
the future authoring program are all
we're all set up long before any of this
happened so I have to clear them out
before I can concentrate on a new
project and I finished a book over the
last couple of years - called 12 rules
for life an antidote to chaos which is
now available by the way if you're
interested on Amazon for pre-order and
so anyways this is my round about way of
saying thank you very much
I can't accept more help at the moment
because my time is too restricted to
make proper use of it so